SPEAKER: The following content
is provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support well help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: The CDMA and the
cellular standard, the IS95,
which is a kind of an old
standard by now, but it's
still widely used.
There's still three major
standards that are used for
cellular communication, cellular
voice communication.
This is one of them.
This is the one which is
primarily being used as a
jumping off point for all of the
new standards that people
are trying to think of.
I want to talk about it for that
reason but also because
it really is a nice way of
pulling together almost
everything we talked about
in the course.
All of it comes into this one
particular way of sending
cellular voice.
Let's go through some of
the details of it.
Some things here might sound
more detailed than what you're
interested in but I think it's
good to have the numbers on it
because it gives you some idea
of which things, which factors
are really relevant and which
ones aren't so relevant.
So it uses a frequency ban from
800 to 900 megahertz.
Most of the new standards that
people are thinking up are up
in the gigahertz range
around two gigahertz
or five or six gigahertz.
I don't know the exact
bandwidths.
All of these bandwidths depend
critically on what the FCC
wants to allocate and also
depend critically one which
particular bands are good for
electromagnetic propagation
and which ones tend to absorb
all of the radiation.
Anyway, you use the band 800 to
850 for the reverse channel
for the cell phone to the base
and you use the band 850 to
900 for the forward channel.
Why do you want to separate the
reverse channels and the
forward channels by as
much as you can?
If you think for just a minute
about the power levels at your
sending antenna, either at the
base station or at the cell
phone itself, and then you think
about how much power
you're receiving, he see there's
an enormous difference
between these two.
Because things get attenuated
enormously after they got
transmitted.
So what you're trying to do is
to filter out what you're
sending, which is an enormously
high power and you
have to filter it out by enough
so that it doesn't
clobber what you're
trying to receive.
This means you need
very good filters.
How do you build very
good filters?
It's a lot easier to build good
filters if you're not
trying to make them cut
off immediately.
If you have 50 megahertz, and
you actually have a lot more
than that, you have exactly 50
megahertz because this is all
separated into a bunch of
different channels.
People in wireless, most
practical communicators, when
they talk about a channel, what
they're talking about is
a particular bandwidth.
All along what we've been
talking about is a particular
medium going from transmitter
to receiver.
That's what they're talking
about is these channels, these
channels or sub-bands are 1.25
megahertz wide each.
We'll see what the
significance of
that is in a while.
So you have a transmit and
receive pair which are both
1.25 megahertz wide and which
are separated by 50 megahertz.
So you have one channel then,
at the bottom of the range,
another channel a little bit
higher, another channel, a
little bit higher, and so
forth all the way up.
So you have lots of different
channels and you put lots of
different cell phones in each
channel for each base station.
So that's roughly the overall
architecture of it.
It's the same kind of system
that we've been
talking about all along.
You start out with voice wave
forms, you have voice
compression.
You then have channel coding,
you then have modulation and
then it goes out
on the channel.
Guess what happens when
it comes back?
You have demodulation, channel
decoding, and then you turn it
back into voice.
Those are the three major steps
which we viewed before
primarily as two steps.
All of the channel stuff is much
harder than all of the
source stuff.
Let's talk about the
source stuff first.
The input voice gets segmented
into these
20 millisecond segments.
Why 20 milliseconds?
Well it sort of seems like it's
probably a number that
somebody picked out of a hat.
It's kind of striking that
all of the standards
use the same interval.
If you think about
it awhile --
I'll talk about this more
on the next slide --
the reason for this interval
is that in voice
communication, delay is
enormously important.
You don't want to have much
delay and since you don't want
to have much delay, you
have to do encoding
over very short segments.
Well anyway, what this does is
it takes each 20 millisecond
segment of voice and it
maps it into 172 bits.
What that means is if you
multiply the 172 by the 50
segments that you have per
second, it comes out to be 8.6
kilobits per second.
That might not sound like
much of an achievement.
Think about the old fashioned
way that people used to encode
voice back in a time when they
were first doing digital
communication.
What you would was you would
think of the voice as having a
bandwidth that went from
about 400 hertz up
to about 3,200 hertz.
You would then view it as a base
band wave form zero to
4,000 hertz.
If you were going to try to
sample that wave form you'd
have to sample it 8,000
times per second.
If you want good quality, you
then have to use a large
number bits.
You need a large number of
bits for each sample.
The standard thing was to use
eight bits per sample.
That gave you 64,000 bits per
second in the old fashioned
way of doing it.
People have worked
for many years.
Many engineers at the old Bell
labs spent their whole career
trying to find out how to
compress voice into smaller
and smaller numbers of bits.
You know, 8.6 kilobits
per second is still
sort of a good rate.
It's still a good rate if you
insist that you have to do it
in 20 millisecond segments.
If you can take much longer
segments to encode voice, you
can do much better.
Voice really has a lot of
constraints over relatively
long periods of time.
Well actually, you know this
because if you take a person's
voice and you map it into text
and then you also add a few
things about pitch and things
like that, you can really come
by with a very small
number of bits.
Here you're constraining
yourself to something that
sounds like the actual voice
and also has to be done in
these 20 millisecond segments
because of delay.
So it still is a reasonably
good achievement.
All of the standards have
figures about like this, in
the same order of magnitude.
I expect that all of
the new standards
will do similar things.
They will probably
have slightly
smaller numbers of bits.
They will probably do much
more computation.
They will achieve a little
bit more because
this was already --
I think --
relatively close to how
far you can go.
The next thing they
do is they add 12
parity checks per segment.
They use that for
error detection.
I don't want to talk about that
a lot because it probably
isn't necessary.
All of the standards do
something or other like this.
The reason is, if you take this
20 millisecond segment
and you go through all of this
enormous processing that we're
going to go through: namely
turning it into an encoded
wave form, transmitting it,
receiving it, detecting it,
doing all the stuff we're
going to do to it.
If you get the 20 millisecond
segment confused, and usually
if you make errors you
make a lot of errors.
If at the receiver you wind up
with the wrong thing, it is
really going to sound awful.
They found that it's much better
if you're not quite
sure of what that segment is,
to just send silence for 20
milliseconds.
The silence is hardly detectable
at all; it just
sounds like good voice.
I mean for most of us it really
sound wonderful to have
a little more silence
than we usually do.
Well enough of that.
Then there's another thing.
This is eight zeros per segments
that are added to
this 172 bits as something which
is called a terminator
for the convolutional code.
I might say a little bit about
that but not much.
So what we've done is to
add 12 bits and eight
bits to this 172 bits.
That brings us up to 192 bits,
which brings us up to 9,600
bits per second which
is what we're now
going to try to transmit.
OK so that's the voice
compression part of the thing
and a little bits of
overhead done for
various special functions.
The main reason I want to talk
about these overhead factors
is that every communication
system I know starts out with
very nice principles studying
very carefully what are the
essential things.
By the time you got done with
it, there are all sorts of
little overhead items that got
thrown in to make the thing
work and it's frustrating
to everybody.
It's usually 10% or 20% of the
capacity of the thing, but
it's always there.
That's why I bring up these
two terms because that's
exactly the kind of things
they're doing.
They're just patching
to make things work.
So you have many details that
lose all of the efficiency
that you would like to have.
Those are what makes it hard to
compare different systems.
Each system, architecturally
nice though it might be to
start with, always winds up
with these little things
because of these silly little
constraints that say, since
you have to have small delay,
you have to segment voice into
segments which are not
much more than 20
milliseconds long.
Those things cause you to
do these other things.
That's where all of
this comes in.
OK, all of the timing in this
IS95 cell phone system,
everything is keyed to this
9,600 bits per second and it's
all keyed through this 20
millisecond interval.
Everything is done in terms of
20 millisecond intervals.
It's all a completely
block system.
The source generates 20
milliseconds worth of data.
You encode that into
a 192 bits.
That gets mapped into some code
word, gets turned into
some high frequency wave form.
At the output you look at 20
milliseconds and that gets
turned back into your best hope
of the 172 bits that you
started with and from there
to some wave form.
Every 20 milliseconds is
completely independent of
every other 20 milliseconds.
You don't even save any
knowledge about what the
channel is between those
periods of time.
Everything is independent
from one to the next.
The point is here, we talked
a great deal about all of
digital communication sort of
being generated from people's
realization that they ought to
separate voice coding from
channel coding.
In other words, there's just
binary interface between all
sources and all channels.
This is a violation
of that; all cell
phones have this violation.
They don't have this pure
separation because all of them
face the fact that to do this
small delay -- anytime you
want to get small delay -- you
have to have some mixing of
what you do with the
source and what
you do with the channel.
The delay has to be some
combination of what happens in
both places.
So, we do have that violation
and it's because of
interactive voice.
You probably never thought about
why it is that you need
small delay on voice.
If you try to talk to somebody
with a 50 millisecond delay,
in between what you're saying
and what the other person is
saying, you will find it turns
you into a stutter in about
five minutes, everyone.
The problem is we all have these
social conventions that
we use to tell us when we can
start to talk when we hear
silence from the other person.
If you have a break in that
routine, even at 50
milliseconds, it totally
screws it up.
Both people start to talk at
the same time and it's very
hard to have a conversation.
Back in the early days of
telephony, they found that
about as much delay as they
could tolerate was about 20
milliseconds.
When it got much longer than
that, it gets very
objectionable.
If you talk to somebody on the
phone who is in Japan, you
have a little more
delay than that.
You find it's very hard
to talk to them.
I mean, you have to practice
a little bit, you have
to think about it.
If it's somebody for whom
English is a second language,
or you have Japanese
as a second
language, it's very easy.
Then you both talk very slowly
so you catch up on that delay.
but.
If you're both talking English
very rapidly, or both Japanese
very rapidly, it becomes
hell on wheels.
As far as the channel is
concerned, we could also do
very well by using longer code
words on the channel.
Again, we're stuck by this
20 milliseconds.
Everything has to be blocked
into 20 millisecond periods.
OK, so the first thing as far
as coding is concerned, is
what's called a convolutional
encoder.
We unfortunately, have not
talked about coding at all in
this course; we're not going
to talk about it.
I just want to enough about
convolutional codes so you get
some idea of what they are.
Here's the simplest example of
a convolutional code that I
think you can think of.
You have a stream of input bits
which are coming in one
per second.
Each time an input bit comes
in, that input bit sits at
this dock here.
I guess most people would prefer
to put an extra memory
element in but it just
complicates the diagram.
You have this input bit, you
have the previous input bit,
and you have the input
bit before that.
What comes out, a time J is a
linear combination of this
bit, that previous bit, and the
bit one bit before that.
You call this a convolutional
code with a constraint length
of two because it has memory
of these two bits.
If you think about it a little
bit, this is a device that has
four states.
OK, because at time J, it needs
to remember whether this
bit was a one or a zero
and whether this bit
was a one or a zero.
So it's just a linear modulo
two device that happens to
have four states.
It produces two bits in each
interval of time which are
functions of this bit and
of the current state.
In this convolutional encoder
which is used in IS95, the
constraint length is eight
instead of two.
In other words, you have 8 of
these memory devices here and
the rate is one-third instead of
one-half Here you have two
bits coming out for
each bit going in.
There you have three
bits coming out for
each bit going in.
It's the same principle.
If you think about it a little
bit, as you increase the
constraint length, the number
of possible states that you
have is going up very rapidly.
So, if you have a constraint
length of eight, which means
eight binary digits stored
there, you have two to the
eighth different states,
which is 256 states.
If you added one more state to
this thing, you would double
the complexity.
Well, it turns out that because
of the way the decoder
works, if you added one more bit
to this block length, it
would multiply the complexity
of the decoder
by a factor of two.
So, when you try to decide how
long these constraint lengths
should be, you have to take into
account that every time
you make it one bit longer,
yes, the thing is going to
work better.
Also, you make it twice
as complex.
Therefore, you have to wait
another six months before you
produce it at the same cost.
OK, we're going to
use a Viterbi
algorithm for decoding.
If you don't know what the
Viterbi algorithm is fine.
If you think in terms of finite
state devices, think of
it this way; you have a device
here which has four states.
Somehow the decoder has to
realize at each instant of
time, if it's gonna decode,
it could either
decode the bits here.
A nicer way to think of it is,
it decodes the state, at each
instant of time.
If it decodes the state at
each instant of time, it
doesn't really have to
have any memory.
As soon as it knows what the
state is at one unit of time,
then it has a very simple
decision to make to figure out
what the incoming bit is and
what the state is at the next
instant of time.
And what a Viterbi decoder is,
is something that does maximum
likelihood decisions
on the state.
There's a nice trellis diagram
to talk about how that's done,
in the notes.
You can read about it,
it's interesting.
Many of you who have probably
seen about it, it's sort of
the easiest thing to
explain, as far as
coding theory is concerned.
It's the easiest thing to
explain until you put all the
notation in.
Then whoever does it, as soon
as they put all of the
notation in, it becomes
a bloody mess.
Anyway, the idea is simple.
So at that point, we can sort
of summarize what we've done
as far as waste compression
and channel coding.
So far, the IS95 standard is
pretty much the same as any
other cellular standard.
All of them, it turns out,
use convolutional codes.
Whether that's a good idea or
not is another question, but
they all do.
It certainly is a very
sensible thing to do.
All of them use the
same segmentation.
All of them use similar
techniques for doing voice
compression.
All of them have all these
little overhead
terms that come in.
If you look at the numbers of
what's going on, we started
out with a 172 bits per second,
which was what comes
out of the voice compressor.
You then have these two
overhead items.
Incidentally this eight bit
convolutional terminator, we
can now get some idea
of what that's for.
You put in your 172 bits here.
You're thinking of this thing in
terms of the state of each
unit of time.
If you're going to figure out
what's going on at the end,
after you put in your 172 bits,
you have to put in a
couple of extra zeros to let
this thing settle down.
You have to let this bit go
all the way through this
device so you got enough
data out about it that
you can decode it.
So that's what that terminator
is for, for putting zeros in
at the end of the sequence so
you can view it all as one
block code.
Again, this is overhead, which
is caused by the need for
small delay.
If you're going to need small
delay, that overhead term
would be much, much smaller.
So at that point, we're up to
9.6 kilobits per second and
we're up 192 bits per segment.
Then we go into this
convolutional encoder and the
convolutional encoder
multiplies things
by a factor of three.
In fact, the rate one-third is
a little bit different for
most of the other standards
because one of the things that
we're going to be doing here,
since we're mapping this input
into one and a quarter mega
bits, that's a considerably
broader band than these
other standards used.
The other standards are quite
narrow band and therefore they
don't want to have a large
number of bits per second.
Here we're going to wind up
talking about 28.8 kilobits
per second at this point which
is 576 bits per second, which
is three times what we
started out with.
We've expanded the number of
bits by a factor of three.
If you question whether this
makes sense to get a slightly
smaller error probability
through coding but increasing
your rate by a factor of three,
that's a perfectly
sensible question to ask.
It just turns out that you do
get a saving from that and
that's what all of coding theory
is about, how much
savings you actually get.
In fact, the savings are
pretty considerable.
So, at this point, we're up
here at 28.8 kilobits per
second with 578, 576
bits per segment.
We then go through
an interleaver.
Don't ask yet what the
interleaver is for.
All the interleaver does is
takes these 576 bits and it's
scrambles them all around.
The receiver knows how they've
been scramble so the receiver
can unscramble them again.
Why you'd need that is something
we will talk about
later, a good deal later.
The next thing we're going to
do, you thought you were
through with coding but no.
In this system, they're actually
two stages of coding
that you go through.
You can view one of them as
modulation instead of coding.
Therefore, you can claim you're
only doing one stage of
coding and one stage of fairly
complex modulation.
You remember when we talked
about orthogonal codewords.
We said we could view orthogonal
codewords almost as
easily, either as a coding
technique or as
a modulation technique.
Mainly, you'd gather together
lots of bits and then you'd
form codewords, which we're
signals, which had a large
number of dimensions in them.
We're going to do the
same thing here.
We are going to take this
interleaver output; we're
going to segment it into
six, six bit blocks.
Then each six bit block is going
to choose one of a set
of 64 orthogonal codewords.
I mean, with six bits, you have
two to the sixth, which
is 64 different combinations.
So, if you're going to use
orthogonal codewords, you need
64 of them.
When we were talking about
orthogonal codewords before,
we didn't quite know how
to generate them.
We then said last time, that may
be using PN sequences is a
nice way of doing it.
That's not quite exact.
Here using Hadamard matrices
is a nice exact
way of doing it.
That happens to be the way it's
done and it's simple.
I mean, you have a Hadamard
matrix for each integer b.
If you start out with b equals
one, which is one bit that you
want to encode.
You have a matrix which consists
of 2 orthogonal
codewords one of which is 0,
0 and the other is 0, 1.
There aren't too many choices
for that and they're all
equivalent.
Then when you want to go to b
equals two, the thing you'd do
is make a matrix and the rows of
the matrix are going to be
the codewords.
The columns correspond to the
bits in the codeword.
The first codeword here is 0,
0 second codeword is 0, 1.
The first codeword here
is 0, 0, 0, 0 the next
one is 0, 1, 0, 1.
For orthogonal codes, the block
lengths of the code and
the number of codewords is
going to be the same.
So the thing you'd do is you
take this matrix, you put it
there, you put it there,
and you put it there.
Then you compliment the matrix
OK why does that work?
Well if we just look at this
part of it, this was an
orthogonal code, this was
an orthogonal code.
In other words, each of them
differ from each of the others
in half the positions, which
is why you think of it as
being orthogonal.
This is the confusion that
runs through all of
communication theory.
We might as well get rid of
that confusion right now.
When you talk about binary
sequences and you say they're
orthogonal, what you mean is, if
you turn that sequence into
a 2PAM signal, those
corresponding signals are
orthogonal.
In other words, an orthogonal
binary sequence, an orthogonal
set of binary sequences is a set
of binary sequences where
each of the sequences differ
from each of the other
sequences in half of
the positions.
Here with these Hadamard
matrices, the way that's done
is that one of the sequences
is always all zero and the
other sequences are all half
ones and half zeros.
It turns out that when you add
any two sequences, add this
sequence to this sequence for
example, you got something
else, which is half ones .
In fact, something else which is
in there, is what's called
a group code.
When you add any two codewords
you got another code.
Anyway, when you look at this,
which is mapped into
here and here --
I think the argument is
difficult here because it's
too simple minded, so you
don't see it in it's
generality -- each time you go
from one b to the next b, the
thing you do is the
same thing.
You start out with this matrix,
put it there, you put
it there, you put it there,
and you put the
complement of it there.
What that does is when you look
at the first half of the
matrix, all of these differ in
half the positions because
they differ in half the
positions here, and they
differ in half the
positions here.
So, they differ in half the
positions over all.
When you look at everything down
here, they differ in half
the positions for the same
reason because complementing
this doesn't change any of those
distance properties.
When you look at the difference
between these and
these, it's the same kind of
thing if you think about it
for a couple of minutes.
So, this is an orthogonal
code.
Why do we want to use this
orthogonal code rather than
just an orthogonal code which
uses the first degree of
freedom and sends an enormous
amount of energy?
Or the second degree of freedom
sends an enormous
amount of energy and so forth?
That's the same thing we were
talking about last time with
regard to channel measurement.
You don't want to send enormous
amounts of energy in
any one degree of freedom.
You want to spread it out over
all the degrees of freedom.
That's what all these codes are
doing; all these codes are
using 2PAM on each
degree of freedom
to generate a codeword.
So the codewords all have sort
of uniform power in them.
OK, so at this point, we have
gone into this orthogonal code
generator with 28.8 kilobits
per second.
We have come out of it with 28.8
kilobits per second times
64 over six.
Namely for each six bit
segment in, we've
gotten 64 bits out.
So the total number of bits that
we have has gone up by a
factor of 64 divided by six.
So we're suddenly up to 307.2
kilobits per second.
What we're trying to do is get
ourselves -- by hook or by
crook -- get ourselves up from
these very small bit rates
that we need to represent voice,
up to these large bit
rates, 1.25 megabits per second,
which we're going to
spread this wave form to.
All the reasons we want to
spread the wave form, I'll
talk about them later.
For now let's just think about
it as saying, somehow or other
we want to spread the wave
form out and turn a small
number of bits into a large
number of bits.
So we've done a pretty
significant part
of that right here.
If we think of turning these
binary rows of the Hadamard
matrix and modulate them
by 2PAM we wind
up with wave forms.
The wave forms are orthogonal.
If you wanted to think of taking
these wave forms and
then transmitting them up to
passband, we would wind up
with the bandwidth
of 307,000 hertz.
That's not enough yet, we want
to go up to 1.25 megahertz.
Anyway, these wave forms are
called Walsh functions.
So the wave forms that you got
from Hadamard matrices are
called Walsh functions.
You have to find something to
honor everybody that's done a
significant amount in this field
and Walsh was one of
these people.
Walsh functions are quite famous
and all they are are
just these orthogonal
wave forms.
So, we now have an orthogonal
code of length 64.
The receiver, I'm going
to talk about the
receiver more later.
In essence, what it's going to
do is take the 64 orthogonal
wave forms, only one of them
will get transmitted in each
of these small units of time.
When the period of time
corresponding to six bits into
the encoder, we have to decode
which of these 64
wave forms was sent.
We're going to do that by
using a rake receiver.
That's what's used in IS95.
This rake receiver is different
from the one we
talked about.
The one we talked about, we were
making a decision between
two hypotheses.
Here we're making a decision
between 64 possible
hypotheses.
If you can remember the
structure of that rake
receiver, it sort of split into
two separate sections.
One section was used for the
decision on one of the wave
forms, the other one, on
the other wave form.
When we do this with 64 wave
forms, it spreads into 64
different sections,
which is why it's
called the rake receiver.
If you draw a picture of
it looks like a rake.
You start out here with the
handle and then you have it
spread out into 64 different
tines and all of these tines
have all of this signal
processing going on.
At the output you come back and
you change what your model
of the channel is depending on
the actual decision that
you've made.
So what we're using is a rake
receiver but a rake receiver
which has 64 decision devices
instead of two.
Suppose we go into an orthogonal
code using seven
bits instead of six bits.
Now, at this point, you're
talking about real money.
OK, because at this point,
you're talking about taking
this rake receiver and turning
it from 64 arms into 128 arms.
Now, you can do that because
these things are essentially
free now and computation
is essentially free.
At the time when this was
designed, there was a very
hard constraint in terms of
complexity about how many bits
they can encode together into
orthogonal wave forms.
I'll show you why
in a little bit.
It wouldn't have done them much
better to have a larger
set of orthogonal wave
forms anyway.
It also uses incoherent soft
decisions as a way of doing
its detection.
We talked about incoherent
detection.
This rake receiver uses that
instead of the coherent
detection that we talked
about in class.
If you just put together in
your mind, the lecture we
spent talking about rake
receivers and the one we spent
talking about incoherent
detection and you put them
together, you have what this
receiver is doing.
I'll talk about just a
little more as we go.
OK, if we now imagine these are
orthogonal codewords and
suppose that each orthogonal
codeword has an
energy e sub s.
Suppose for the time being
that the channel is
represented perfectly by a
single-tap model and we know
what the energy in that
single-tap model is.
We don't know what the
phase so we're
using incoherent detection.
What's the error probability?
Well the error probability for
an incoherent receiver for
making a decision between two
possibilities was one-half
times e to the minus energy
divided by 2 N 0.
Here we have 64 different
possibilities.
So we're going to transmit one
of these wave forms and we now
use the union band to say
there's this probability of
error to each of the other
63 possible wave forms.
we could make an error
to any one of them.
That's equally likely to make
an error to any one of them
because they're each orthogonal
to the one that
we're dealing with.
So this is a reasonably good
bound on the error
probability.
OK, now you go back from this to
look at the reason why, one
of the main reasons why
you want to do this.
E sub s is the amount of energy
you use to transmit six
bits instead of one bit.
Therefore, when you look at the
energy per bit that you're
using, it's e sub s
divided by six.
So, your probability of error,
-- if in fact you were making
hard decisions at the output of
this incoherent detector --
would be in the order of 63 over
2 times e to the minus
3eb over N0.
This is a considerably larger
exponent and therefore, a
considerably lower error
probability than we were
getting when we were
talking about
transmitting single bits.
In other words, the same thing
is going on here as was going
on when we were talking about
getting up the channel
capacity using a large number
of orthogonal wave forms.
It's the same idea.
When you encode lots of bits
together, you make a joint
decision on all of them,
you make a gain.
That's exactly what's
happening here.
You made a gain because you've
taken the amount of energy
that you have available for
each one of your bits and
you've combined it all
so that you get this
bigger exponent in here.
If you're lucky, the exponent
is big enough that it
overwhelms this term and your
decision comes out with very
small error probability.
Well, as it turns out, we're not
interested in making these
hard decisions.
What we're really interested
in doing is just sending a
likelihood ratio back to this
Viterbi decoder which it can
use in making final decisions.
To see how well that's going to
work, this is exactly the
thing you want to look at.
This is what's telling you, if
E b is large enough your
decisions, if you had to make
them, would be very good.
Therefore, if instead of making
decisions, you pass
likelihood ratios on, those
likelihood ratios are going to
have a lot of information
in them.
Essentially, those likelihood
ratios tell you what those
codewords are.
OK, now, the effect of fading
is to change this E sub b
because when we were talking
about this incoherent
detection, we were looking at
the energy per bit after going
through the channel.
So, this is the error
probability for a particular
received energy per bit.
Sometimes when the channel is
badly faded, this number is
very small.
This bound is a lot bigger than
one but you don't care
about it because the bound
is no good then.
When the channel is good, this
number is large and this
probability there is very small
and your likelihood
ratios give you a lot
of information.
If you had multitap diversity
instead of the single-tap
here, if you have
a lot of taps.
If you have a lot of taps you
can visualize this as getting
independent readings
on the channel.
Therefore, you can view it
as getting independent
information about the bits that
were sent and this is
what diversity is.
I mean, the trouble with these
Rayleigh fading channels is
when they're faded there's
nothing you can do.
If you have multiple taps
instead of one tap, then in
fact, you have diversity
between all of them.
If any of them are good,
then you decode.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: You were saying
earlier that PAM is not ideal
[INAUDIBLE].
[INAUDIBLE]
Why is the standard using 2PAM
instead of pulse position
modulation?
PROFESSOR: Well because it's
using these long codewords.
Because back when we were
analyzing it, we were
analyzing it using
two codewords.
Those two codewords were
orthogonal to each other.
We could have made them plus
one minus one and plus one
minus one for the other one if
we had in fact known what the
channel was ahead of time, OK.
That brings up a good point
because you have to get to
started somehow.
I mean you have to know somehow,
what's going on at
the channel at the point
where you start.
I'm not going to talk
about that.
If you have this multitap
diversity than E sub b is
going to be better
than it would be.
Otherwise, this says, if you can
make the bandwidth bigger,
as you make the bandwidth
bigger, the bits
are coming in faster.
As the bits are coming in
faster, this bit time is the
separation between the taps
and this digital model.
So that as you make the
bandwidth bigger, you
automatically get
more diversity.
You get more taps in this
discrete model.
Looking at it another way, you
have a certain frequency
coherence in the channel.
If you're sending a broad
bandwidth, you get lots of
different frequencies.
If you get lots of different
frequencies, there's a good
chance that one of
them is good.
OK, so we are going to get some
gain in diversity there.
Typically we're going to get a
relatively large amount of
energy if the thing works.
Well, now we come to a question
that we've been
carefully avoiding all term.
It's sort of the question of,
if you make codewords
orthogonal or if you make
codewords have nice structure
at the input to a channel and
the channel has some strange
behavior, what's going to be
the output of the channel?
What we're doing here is
making our codewords
orthogonal at the input of the
channel, we can't guarantee
that they're still orthogonal
at the output.
What we do know is that PN
sequences are almost
orthogonal anyway.
If you put PN sequence through
anything, they still look like
PN sequences.
In other words, if you think
of a PN sequence as an IID
binary sequence, and you have
a very long IID binary
sequence, and you corrupt it
in any way you want to, it
still looks like an IID
binary sequence.
So, the point is, if you can
make these orthogonal
codewords look more like PN
sequences, you can make them
behave better at the output of
the channel as well as the
input to the channel.
So you'll get something that
looks orthogonal whether the
channel essentially looks like
a one tap channel or a
multiple tap channel.
OK, we also have bandwidth to
burn because we're only up to
307 kilohertz.
What they decided to do was to
take a PN sequence and run it
at four times the speed
of this bit sequence.
So we have bits coming in at
307,000 bits per second.
We're going to have a PN
sequence which is changing
four times for each bit time.
So suddenly we're increasing the
speed of this whole system
by a factor of four.
For every one bit, we multiply
it by a sequence of four bits.
So instead of getting a change
every one over 307,000
seconds, you now get a change
every one over 1.2288
millionths of a second.
So, suddenly you're up to a
sequence which is right at the
bandwidth you want.
I mean we want it to get
up to 1.25 megahertz.
Suddenly, we're up so close to
that it's going to be a real
challenge to build a filter,
which will really make the
output look like it's limited
to this 1.25 megahertz.
So we need very tight
filters here.
If you multiply this PN sequence
, you're using the
same PN sequence on all of
the orthogonal codewords.
If you think just a little bit
about it, if these orthogonal
codewords --
I'm I mean think of them still
as binary sequences --
if each of them differ from each
other when in half the
places, when you multiply both
of them by this PN sequence,
they're still gonna differ
in half the places.
You still got the
same affect out.
They're still perfectly
orthogonal before going
through a channel but now you
have a good chance that
they're pretty close to
orthogonal after going through
the channel.
So, suddenly, we've got
it up to the bandwidth
we want to be at.
There's another reason
for the PN sequence.
I mean, so far we've been
thinking in terms of, how do
you build a cell phone
and a base station so
they will work together?
Actually, you want to build a
base station and thousands of
cell phones so they'll
work together.
So you want some way of making
different cell phones look
different from each other.
What they use this PN sequence
for is to make different cell
phones look different.
Each cell phone is going to
start out on this PN sequence
at a different point.
The PN sequence is going to be
generated by a 42 bit feedback
shift register.
If you don't know what a
feedback shift register is,
don't worry about it.
Most of you probably do.
A 42 bit feedback shift
register, with the right kind
of settings in it, is going to
generate a periodic sequence
with a period of two to the
forty second minus one, which
is about four times
10 to the twelfth.
It doesn't repeat very often.
I mean, this really
looks like an IID
sequence and binary digits.
It really goes through every non
zero 42 bit combination in
this period here.
It has very nice properties
to it.
But the property we want for
this system is that in fact,
when you give a cell phone a
particular setting in that
shift register, it starts it off
generating a PN sequence
which looks totally different
from that generated by any
other cell phone.
That's the only thing that makes
these different cell
phones different.
It's enough to make each one
of them look orthogonal to
each of the others.
OK, their basements sequences
and thus passband wave forms
are now going to be essentially
orthogonal to
those of other cell phones.
In other words, at this point,
we're sort of going into
fantasy world.
I mean, we started out
generating 64 wave forms which
were strictly orthogonal
to each other.
Then we said we want these
wave forms to still be
orthogonal after we go through
this unknown channel.
We said, well we can do
this by making them
look like PN sequences.
But the other thing that PN
sequences do, is it all of the
possible wave forms for one
cellphone will look orthogonal
to the wave forms for all of
the other cell phones.
So that in fact, what's
happening is, if you look at a
base station, and the base
station is trying to receive
information from each cell
phone, what it receives from
one cell phone is going to be
essentially independent of
what it receives from
the next cell phone.
Now if we think of the base
station as trying to receive
what's coming from one cell
phone, what's the interference
from the other cell phone
going to look like?
We're going to take thousands
and thousands of sequences,
which are now turned into wave
forms, which look like IID
wave forms, IID binary wave
forms, and now we're adding
together a large
number of them.
They fill up the whole
spectrum uniformly.
So they have a spectral
density --
I mean it's a random process
-- and it has a spectral
density which is flat over this
bandwidth of 1.25 megahertz.
And you've added a lot of them
together, so it looks like
white noise.
So the effect of these other
cell phones is just like a
small addition of white noise
as far as trying to detect
what's going on at
one cell phone.
Now, in fact you could be very
clever here because, as soon
as a base station decodes one
cell phone, it can say, I know
what that wave form was,
subtracts it off from the
received wave form, and uses
that to help in decoding other
wave forms.
These standards do not
do anything as
sophisticated as that.
Lots of papers talk
about doing it.
Information theorists
love this idea.
I think it's one of these ideas
that sooner or later, ah
going to become practical.
As soon as it becomes
practical,
everyone will use it.
What does it take to
become practical?
For someone to use it, because
we all know it'll work.
It's just a matter of
actually doing it.
But anyway, it's not done now.
All of these interferes are just
going to look like white
noise as far as this
one cellphone
detection is concerned.
Now, if we compare this IS95
system with all of the narrow
band systems that people use, at
this point you can find the
main difference between these
different systems.
When you use a narrow band
system, things are a ranged so
that only one cell phone is
talking to one base station on
one of these narrow bands
of frequency.
Namely the channels are very
narrow but because they're
narrow if you have two cell
phones which are using that
same bandwidth, they're just
going to interfere with each
other totally.
You won't get through.
So each cell phone which is
using one base station has to
be using a different
narrow bandwidth.
Cell phones using different
adjoining base stations are
also going to have to
use different bands.
In fact, that's a terribly
complicated problem just
because these base stations
are put in sort of, random
locations and trying to program
things in such a way
that you don't have two cell
phones which are using
adjacent base stations using
the same frequency.
It's a real nightmare.
So, you're going to have cell
phones using the same base
station, which are a little
bit separated, but still
because of all sorts of
channeling effects and strange
electromagnetic effects, base
stations still receive data
from these far away
cell phones.
They're also trying to receive
data from the cell phone
that's using that frequency.
So you got a lot of interference
in these narrow
band systems; you got a lot of
interference from cell phones
using different base stations.
In the IS95 system, you get more
interference from cell
phones that are using this
particular base station
because they're all using
the same bandwidth.
They all just look like white
noise to each other.
So they do interfere with
each other, they
raise the noise level.
When you look at the
interference with cell phones
using other base stations, it's
not catastrophic like it
is with these narrow
band systems.
So what you effectively wind
up with is that in the IS95
system, you have more
interference within a base
station but less interference
between base stations.
In the narrow band systems you
have no interference within a
base station but considerable
interference
between base stations.
Which is better?
Nobody really knows.
Well except for the fact that
almost all new systems are
planning to use CDMA.
It seems that most people have
sort of agreed that you get
less noise, overall, if
you're using if you're
using a CDMA system.
So that let's us sort of
summarize where we are with
all of this.
We started out with 28.8
kilobits per second.
We then going into this Walsh
function, orthogonal wave form
and coder, which comes
out with 307.2
kilobits per second.
We then multiplied by this long
PN sequence, 42 bits long
with four bits coming in here
for each bit coming in here.
Now we're implementing this and
anybody with any sense who
was trying to implement PN
sequences with multipliers
would just say, I don't want
to turn things into to PAM
sequences yet.
I want to keep them binary
and add them mod 2
because that's easier.
So all of this is still
mod 2 binary digits.
This is mod 2 binary digits.
The only thing we haven't talked
about yet is now they
throw in two other
PN sequences.
One on the real part of what's
going on here and one on the
quadrature part.
The thing they're doing is
taking this one sequence,
splitting it into two parts;
adding a PN sequence here,
then doing the 2PAM, then
filtering and sending this
stuff out on the cosign
channel and the stuff out
on the sign channel.
I've never had a very good sense
of why you need these
two PN sequences here.
I can like sort of explain it
to you in the following way.
If you didn't have PN sequences
here, what you'd be
doing here is simply sending
this same sequence twice.
So you be sending it on the
cosign channel, you'd be
sending it on the sign channel,
which would sort of
be equivalent to sending
it at 45 degrees.
Once you realize that, you say
well, I might as well leave
this whole thing out and just
use the cosign channel and
nothing else.
If I'm just using the cosign
channel and nothing else it
won't make much difference
because the cosign just refers
to the phase at this
transmitter.
I'm talking about many cell
phones whose transmitters are
all at different places relative
to a base station.
Therefore, they're all going to
be using different phases
so they're all going to fill
up the signal space.
The thing that, that doesn't
take into account is the fact
that if we do that we're not
using all the degrees of
freedom available to us.
We're still just using the
number of degrees of freedom
that we got here, which are
real degrees of freedom.
When we do this and this,
we got twice as
many degrees of freedom.
The PN sequences that we're
looking at, which are the
things that are orthogonal
to each other.
We have twice as many bits in
a give interval of time when
we have these two PN sequences
as we do when we only use this
one PN sequence.
So in fact, if we view PN as
IID binary digits, you get
twice as many binary digits this
way as you got before.
Therefore, everything
works better.
You come much closer to being
orthogonal with higher
probabilities.
If you didn't understand
that's fine.
It's not explained in
the notes either.
the IS95 standard.
I think the explanation is
right but it needs some
fleshing out.
OK, here's another interesting
feature
about this rake receiver.
It doesn't use this digital
model of the channel that
we've talked about.
It in fact, uses the analogue
base band model.
In other words, the base band
model of the channel is the
channel is represented
by an analog filter.
The analogue filter has impulses
or almost impulses at
different delays.
Now what you'd like to do in
this rake receiver here is
instead of having taps at these
sample times for the
given bandwidth, they're going
to adjust the taps so the taps
are right on top of these things
that look like impulses
in all of these path returns.
So the question is, what's the
difference between these two
strategies?
I mean, we sort of show that
the digital model was
completely equivalent
to the analog model.
Then I cheated you; I didn't
realize I cheated you until
about nine o'clock
this morning.
I cheated you in the following
way: I told you that if you
model the channel in terms of
the discrete set of taps
according to the sampling
therom, this was completely
equivalent to trying to model it
-- as far as a band limited
input was concerned -- in terms
of an analog filter.
That's absolutely right if you
use an infinite number of taps
for the channel.
If you now say that the impulse
response of the
channel is about one tap long
and then you say, how many
tabs do I need to
represent it?
It's an interesting question
because if the impulse
response is one tap long and you
filter to look like a sign
x over x, the impulse response
can look like this.
So you have one tap here, one
tap here, which is zero, one
tap here, one tap here,
which is zero.
If you've gotten your spacing
off by half a cycle, what do
you have then?
You have a tap here.
You have these taps which are
going down as one over time.
So in fact, modeling this
kind of thing with one
tap would be terrible.
Now when you use the analog
filter and you actually put
these taps of the rake receiver
at the places where
you have actual physical
responses you do much better.
You particularly do better if
the impulse response duration
of the channel is the same order
of magnitude as 1 over
the bandwidth of the source
that you're using.
At that point this becomes
an important issue.
That's exactly the situation
we have here because of the
impulse response of
these channels.
The sample time on this discrete
model it's about
eight-tenths of a microsecond.
If you think of how far light
can travel in eight-tenths of
a microsecond, it's about the
same as the multipath spreads
you would find outdoors
when you're in a
relatively rural area.
If you're in a city area,
multipath spreads are going to
be even smaller.
So if you want to a rake
receiver to work well you
should really have a rake
receiver which is trying to
zero in on the actual physical
response times.
This is what this system does.
They did it right and
I did it wrong.
OK, final thing.
I told you I wanted to talk
about why we did scrambling.
This rake decoder, in other
words, this decision device,
which every six bits tries to
make a decision on these 64
different orthogonal
wave forms.
You can just make hard decisions
which gives you six
bits out each time.
You can produce six bits out
also with some likelihood
about how likely they
are to be right.
So what you'd like is some
information which is
essentially the logarithm of
the probability of being
correct over the probability
of error.
You can estimate that in
your rake receiver.
You can estimate it by knowing
whether you're making a close
call or whether there's one
orthogonal wave form which is
far more likely than
all of the others.
So if you're making a close
call, then you produce an
output that says, I think
it's this output but
I'm not very sure.
This is what goes into
this viterbi decoder.
The viterbi decoder, since it's
operating on these states
-- in other words, it's
operating on what it
visualizes is being the state
of the viterbi decoder --
it can actually deal with these
log likelihood ratios as
well as anything else.
That's one of the reasons you
want to use a viterbi decoder
because most coding devices
that people have invented
don't work very well with
analog signals.
This does work well with
The problem is, anytime you
make a mistake on the 64
orthogonal wave forms, you
have a six bit batch of
digits, a six bit block, and
you're going to be wrong,
typically in three of them.
well, you're going to be wrong
in a random number of them.
Half the time you're
going to be wrong.
What this means is if you put
this data into a decoder, what
you're going to find is that
every time there's an error in
the in the rake receiver, you're
going to have a burst
of errors, some random bunch
of errors over six bits.
This is typically going to be in
the order of three bits an
error all at once.
If you look at the structure of
that decoder, anytime you
got a large number of errors in
all at once, it's going to
screw the thing up terribly.
I'll give you one
example of that.
You can take a much simpler
coding example.
Suppose you transmit either
all zeros, seven zeros or
seven ones.
At the receiver there's a
certain probability that you
make an error on each
one of these bits.
You first make a decision on
each bit and then after that
you make a decision on
the whole code word.
If the bit errors are
independent of each other,
then you make an error in the
overall detection of these
code words only when you make
four errors out of seven.
Or five errors out of seven
which is negligible.
So you calculate, what's the
probability of making four
errors out of seven here?
Well it's the number of
combinations of seven things
taken three at a time which is
35 times p fourth, p to the
fourth power which is
the probability
of making four errors.
If those bits are perfectly
correlated mainly, if whenever
you make one bit error you make
all seven bit errors,
then the probability of error is
p If p is relatively small,
p is always a lot bigger than
35 times p to the fourth.
In other words, the lesson here
is that highly dependent
errors cause trouble for
any kind of decoder.
Now you see why you had the
scrambler in here, why you
have the interleaver.
You Have the interleaver to take
these highly correlated
errors which are coming out of
the rake receiver where you
make blocks of six errors all
tend to appear together.
You're scrambling them out so
they're widely separated so
that the viterbi decoder is
able to deal with them.
That's the last piece
of the whole thing.
I could talk a little bit about
how the viterbi decoder
works but I think you're
probably exhausted by now.
I think I will stop
at this point.
Than you all for your attention
all term and good
luck on the final.